so I know you've got the prequel
novellas out there but dnj Steve and
Lisa and San Diego asks would you ever
consider writing a prequel to Song of
Ice and Fire series once it's violently
done such as the backstory of Liana and
Rhaegar or nits and Robert they'd love
to see how it all started and by the way
when you're answering the questions feel
free to correct the pronunciation it's
okay look a few times you know I I don't
have any plans to do any of those
stories but I never rule anything out
you know if I get an inspiration or one
of those stories suddenly takes hold of
my imagination it will let go sure maybe
I'll maybe I'll do something like that
one of the things I've been trying to do
with the series is is to tell these
stories tell the stories of Robert's
rebellion and some of the stories of the
history of Westeros in success of
Revelations and flashbacks and people
remembering things so at the same time
the story is moving forward it's also
kind of moving backward and gaps are
being filled in and you're learning like
you hear about this event and in the
first book and then you're a little more
about it and in the second book and then
the third book you hear about it from a
different person who has a very
different version of what happened from
the previous versions you've heard and
then there's just hole in it which gets
filled in the fourth book so I hope by
the time it's all finished I will have
expanded backwards as well as gone
forwards and many of the many of the
gaps will have been filled in and you'll
know more about the whole Robert and
Rhaegar and everything like that
but well it's not quite the same as
telling a story about them I realized I
still have two more gigantic books to
write though so and six years to finish
them in bright yes I'm very fast so
I don't know what I'm gonna write after
that you know whatever whatever seizes
me I mean I like to do different things
as as a writer this is a this has been a
huge project certainly the biggest thing
I've ever done in my my life or career
but I've done other things and hope to
continue to do other things I much as I
love ice and fire and fantasy I also
love science fiction I want to do more
science fiction work I want to do more
short stories I love doing those wild
cards which is a series I've been
working on even longer than Ice and Fire
I've been in the beginning of wild cards
I wrote a lot for it as well as editing
it now the series is still ongoing
mostly I edit these days because they
don't have time to write for it but I'd
love to go back and and write some more
wildcard material about some of the
characters for that so what would I feel
like writing after those six years
they're done who knows whatever I feel
like writing on that particular day